[Musique]
c'est une affaire parmi d'autres qui à
l'époque n'évoque n'éveille surtout
aucune
passion on se rend compte de plus en
plus qu'il existe quelques part une i
justice
faire un Paris à un moment donné qu'on
allait faire avancer la loi dans le
cadre d'une affaire
[Musique]
judiciaire c'est le dénouement de 3
jours de procès éprouvant et la soirée
s'annonce encore longue à Blois les
jurés délibèrent depuis plusieurs heures
dans la brasserie près de la cour
d'appel les pronostics vont bon train
Jacqueline sauvage sera-t-elle de
nouveau
condamnée sur internet de nombreuses
féministes partout en France attendent
elles aussi le
[Musique]
verdict après 5 he de délibérer le
coupré tombe je suis
désolé pour le le meurtre de son mari
Jacqueline sauvage et cop de 10 ans de
prison une double peine pour cette femme
battue durant 47 ans elle est où
l'humanité dans tout ça je me demande on
a l'impression qu'on a une une époque où
il y a plus plus d'humanité quoi il y a
plus de sentiment c'est marcheou crève
marche ou
crève c'est une scène forcément chargée
d'émotion parce que les trois filles je
crois espérer beaucoup dans la défense
des avocates de Jacqueline sauvage donc
évidemment c'est une douche froide parce
que le verdict de bois vient strictement
confirmer celui d'Orléan donc en fait on
a l'impression que c'est un un procès
pour
rien ce soir-là ni la famille ni les
avocates ne souhaitent se pourvoir en
cassation c'est la fin de l'affaire
judiciaire et pourtant l'histoire va
continuer sur internet à 300 km de Blois
à ClermontFerrand Karine Plard militante
féministe lance une bouteille à la
MRE je suis à la sortie du travail je je
vois le verdict tombé je rentre chez moi
et je me dis on peut pas enfin voilà
faut que faut que je puisse exprimer
tout ça je décide de de lancer une
pétition en fait et je me suis dit bah
voilà bah demandons une grâce
présidentielle parce que après tout elle
en est là aussi parce que les pouvoir
public ne font pas ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui en terme d'accompagnement et
de protection des femmes victimes de
violence je justice sauvage libéré Jaine
justice sauvage libéré
justice comme d'autres associations
féministes les féèes s'emparent de
l'affaire Jacqueline sauvage est alors
incarcéré à
Sarang la pétition pour demander sa
libération fait le tour du web
l'indignation prend aussi de l'ampleur
sur les réseaux
[Musique]
sociaux il y a sur
internet à nouveau une possibilité un
espace public un espace de réflexion un
espace de contradiction où des gens
s'expriment sur un fait et les
conséquences qu'on doit lui attacher et
ça c'est quelque chose à mon avis
qui pour nous enfin au sein de la
justice nous boulve un peu dans nos
habitudes faut bien le dire gr et
liberté
àop profé le procès de Jacqueline
sauvage sur Internet et très vite la
colère descend dans la rue on a la manif
le 21 janvier qui pour moi et le déclic
en fait et là euh on est 300
manifestants donc c'est pas la manif du
siècle non plus on est que 300 dans la
rue euh alors avec pas mal de collectifs
féministes qui sont présents que ça soit
le féminisme les féèes et cetera
euh et des centaines de journalistes
quoi et donc on passe je sais pas 2h3 3h
à répondre à des interviews sur des
grands médias
nationaux et donc là il y a un
emballement médiatique qui qui se fait
un tsunami médiatique mais aussi
politique plusieurs personnalités vont
prendre parti pour Jacqueline sauvage
une députée va même proposer de rendre
pénalement irresponsable les femmes qui
se vengent de leur conjoint violent
l'affaire suscite passion et et la
frénésie continue de se propager sur
Internet ce qui est très frappant c'est
de constater que la plupart des
personnes qui réagissent sur Internet
sont des personnes qui évidemment n'ont
pas assisté au procès mais ça on peut
pas le r vouloir mais qui souvent n'ont
pas pris la peine d'aller plus loin que
les quelques lignes qu'elles ont pu lire
et à partir de là elles ont fait leur
propre interprétation et considérer que
Jacqueline sauvage effectivement n'avait
rien à faire en prison
Jacqueline sauvage victime de son mari
violent mais Jacqueline sauvage bel et
bien coupable de
meurtre une femme aux multiples visages
une personnalité qui
intrigue c'est quelqu'un qui dont on va
dire qu'elle a son caractère euh et
qu'elle pouvait aussi ne pas se laisser
faire je pense d'ailleurs que pour vivre
47 années au côté de nor Marou il
fallait aussi avoir un caractère assez
trempé et c'est vrai que Jacqueline
sauvage c'est quelqu'un qui je crois
avait besoin de prendre une revanche
sociale et notamment une revanche
vis-à-vis de sa famille on lui disait de
toute façon nbert Marot c'est pas
quelqu'un pour toi je crois qu'elle a
voulu démontrer que si et que tous les
deux il pouvaient monter quelque chose
d'abord un couple pu une famille puis
une entreprise je crois que c'est sa
fierté Jacqueline sauvage en murit dans
les névroses de son drame conjugale une
femme décrite comme froide lors de son
premier procès son apparition en appel
sera totalement
différente on découvre cette femme qui
elle-même a changé complètement
d'attitude c'est vrai qu'elle a
maintenant plus d'un an de détention
hormi la détention Bror qu'elle avait
fait auparavant elle est en détension
depuis plus d'un an elle a vieilli euh
elle a les cheveux gris ramassés en C
cheval et
surtout elle a un comportement bien plus
humain que celui qu'elle avait en
premierère instant c'est-à-dire que pour
la première fois Jacqueline sauvage
pleure des larmes à l'évocation de son
calvaire des larmes aussi lorsque ces
filles racontent comment leur père les a
violé une attitude qui va pourtant pas
émouvoir la présidente le parti prix de
la présidence cétait on la juge comme
une meurtrière ok c'est ce qu'elle est
en effet elle a assassiné mais sans
prendre à aucun moment en compte le fait
qu'elle a été victime pendant 47 ans et
que si elle a fini par passer à l'acte
c'était dans un acte de survie moi je
pense que quelque part on a tenu compte
dans le verdict de sa situation puisque
je rappelle quand même qu'on était sur
une peine encourue qui est la perpétuité
et que nous sommes à 10
ans 10 ans de réclusion
[Musique]
criminelle je pense que la présidente a
craint la surmédiatisation du procès et
que elle ne voulait
pas encore une fois ne voulait pas que
ce soit le procès des violences au sein
du
couple et pourtant c'est bien la
stratégie que la défense va adopter lors
de ce second
procès Jaqueline sauvage symbole de la
cause des femmes battues Jacqueline
sauvage victime qui aurait agi en état
de légitime défense
différé cette femme
représente toutes les femmes battues
pendant de très longues années on l'a
rappelé aujourd'hui 47 ans de violence
conjugale quotidienne
répétitive 47 ans 50 ans c'est une vie
et ces femmes-là ont un un
posttraumatisme qui est évidemment très
très très important et qui peut
expliquer le passage à
[Musique]
l'acte Jacqueline sauvage a changé
d'avocat elle a abandonné l'avocat de
notargouis qui la défend en première
instance pour être assisté par deux
avocates parisiennes qui ne font pas
mystère de leur stratégie qui s'appuient
d'ailleurs sur un premier procès où
étaient intervenu ces deux avocates qui
est le procès d'Alexandra lange en 2012
devant les assises de Douet où une femme
a été effectivement acquittée alors
qu'elle avait tué son mari sauf que la
légitime défense a été retenue dans ce
cas pour des raisons bien précises au
moment où Alexandre lange se saisit d'un
couteau et poignard son époux celui-ci
est tout de même en train de l'étrangler
là dans le cas Jacquine sauvage on n'est
pas du tout dans la vicine défense très
honnêtement je pense que euh ce choix
était un choix
risqué faire un Paris à un moment donné
qu'on allait faire avancer la loi dans
le cadre d'une affaire judiciaire
l'angle de défense Ctait quelque chose
qui n'existait pas dans le code pénal et
donc à part on peut pas reprocher pour
le coup là à une présidente de dire le
droit et de ne dire que le droit
et donc il y a le ton des parlementaires
qui font des projets de loi qui déposent
des projets de loi et puis il y a le
temps judiciaire et je pense que le fait
d'avoir mélangé les deux a été quelque
chose qui qui a qui n'a pas aidé
Jacqueline
sauvage faute d'avoir convaincu le
pouvoir judiciaire c'est donc un autre
pouvoir qui va se pencher sur
l'affaire sous la pression
politico-médiatique François Hollande
sort enfin du
silence les trois filles et les avocates
de Jacqueline sauvage sont reçu à
l'Élysée la pétition pour on demander la
grâce à atteint les 400000
signatures nous on avait déjà édité les
signatures et cetera pour les filles de
Jacqueline sauvage qui avait fait
officiellement la demande de grâce à
François Hollande avec les les
avocates et on avait pas de nouvelle ça
faisait 15 jours qu'elles avaient déposé
la demande de grâce il y avait eu aucun
signe ni de la garde des sauts puisque
le dossier doit passer par la garde des
saut ni du président de la République et
puis là ça s'emballe on entend diverses
choses oui il veut recevoir la famille
il veut recevoir le comité de soutien et
cetera il veut recevoir tout le monde et
puis donc on apprend qu'il va recevoir
la famille et les avocates à l'Élysée
s'il vous PLT 48 heures après
l'entretien le président accorde une
grâce partielle à Jacqueline sauvage il
s'est passé seulement 2 mois entre le
verdict et la décision de François
Hollande ce qui est complètement fou
c'est
surtout que une pétition en ligne que
qu'un mouvement comme celui-là a pu
avoir
un effet au plus haut sommet de
[Musique]
l'État je crois sauvage été dépassé par
tout ce qui s'est passé elle s'attendait
pas à ça elle ne s'attendait pas à
devenir une icône
[Musique]
elle est fatigué ça se
comprend trs bien malgré elle oui c'est
une icône c'est la représentant des
femmes battues mais c'est pasce qu'elle
voulait fa sauvage il y a une différence
entre le fait qu'on essaie de comprendre
au travers de son affaire tout ce qui
manque sur ces questions là dans notre
société et le fait d'en avoir fait une
icône et et je pense qu'on l' un peu
prise au piège aussi par rapport à ça et
ça et ça c'est pas bien parce que on n
pas le droit de décider de la vie des
gens et et c'est à elle de décider de sa
vie quand elle sortira de prison et à
elle de décider de savoir quelle suite
elle veut donner à tout ça ou
[Musique]
pas Jacqueline sauvage icône malgré elle
elle qui n'aura jamais rien revendiqué
de son existence près de 50 ans de
violence une vie entière de silence à la
selle sur le
BIA le drame conjugal d'une femme devenu
l'emblème de toute une
cause